Hey, Thoughty2 here.
Have you ever heard of the world’s deadliest fart?
No? Well, let me lead you to Cameroon, celebrated
for its coffee, cotton and cacao. And don’t forget
its football team, the Indomitable Lions, who’ve
qualified for the World Cup 9 times – a feat
unequalled by any other African team. Their best
performance came in 1990 when they made it to
the quarter-finals and were narrowly defeated
by the Three Lions of England in extra time.
England progressed to the semi-finals, only
to continue its venerable custom of losing
on penalties, but that’s a story best left for
another time or, more likely, another channel.
Anyway, let’s get back to that fatal fart.
Cameroon has a population of 25 million people
and over 250 native languages, but in scientific
circles, there stirs a story so surreal it has
eternally solidified Cameroon on the world map.
On the 21st of August 1986, in the desolate
reaches of Lake Nyos in the North-West, there was
a natural disaster - or more accurately, a limnic
eruption. This catastrophe claimed the lives of
around 1,800 people and 3,500 livestock, and even
though it was technically a volcanic eruption,
it wasn’t anything like the kind you and I know.
Instead of a spewing torrent of lava and smoke,
this eruption materialised as a giant gas cloud.
Lake Nyos is a deep crater lake located high
on the side of an inactive volcano in the
Oku volcanic plain and forms part of a 1,600km
chain of volcanoes known as the ‘Cameroon line’.
Now, if someone tried to peddle you a property
perched on the precipice of a volcano,
you’d probably pass it up. Still, the areas
around volcanoes are fantastically fertile
places for farming and, therefore, densely
populated. Just ask the two million people
who now live in the vicinity of Mount Vesuvius
near Naples - because who cares about trifling
tales such as the destruction of Pompeii and
Herculaneum when you can cultivate the world’s
best tomatoes in the rich volcanic soil and make
the most divine pizzas known to man? Anyway,
you get the point, and sure enough, in 1986,
the area around Lake Nyos was home to a large
populace of people farming crops and cattle.
The Bafmen, who have inhabited the area for
centuries, were some of the earliest settlers.
As a rule, they only built their houses on
elevated ground above a lake, never below it – a
tradition rooted in local folklore that describes
lakes doing mysterious things like rising and
falling, changing locations, or even blowing up.
Scholars speculate these beliefs
were borne from bygone events
and passed down through the type of
oral tradition that nobody records,
but we really probably should. If only they had,
perhaps thousands of lives would have been saved.
You see, there was a ticking time bomb about
50 miles beneath the lake in the form of a
silent but deadly magma chamber. Gradually, the
magma released gases, including carbon dioxide,
which filled the surrounding rock
before seeping into the lake itself.
This exact process is only known to occur
in a few lakes worldwide, but most notably:
Lake Kivu in the Democratic Republic of the
Congo, and Lake Monoun, also in Cameroon.
After travelling through the rock, the
gas dissolves into the water. When the
lake's waters are stratified and don’t mix, a
considerable buildup of gas on the lower layers,
particularly Carbon Dioxide, can occur. It can sit
stably in this state for some time, but a sudden
mixing of the upper and lower levels results in
a limnic eruption. It’s like opening a bottle
of champagne. Or, for the more lewd learners
out there - it’s like farting in the bath.
This is precisely what happened at Lake Nyos.
However, several weeks before the calamitous
combustion, a chilling sight greeted the
locals one morning. All the fish in the
lake had perished overnight, their lifeless
bodies drifting on the surface. It transpired
that the carbon dioxide levels had attained
a fatal concentration in the lake's depths,
asphyxiating nearly all living creatures within.
Then, a few weeks later, came the explosion.
And ever since, we’ve been trying to figure out
what had disturbed this deadly carbon dioxide
cache. Perhaps it was a rock fall that mixed
the water layers. It could have been a minor
earthquake or even a small volcanic eruption at
the bottom of the lake – even though no tremors
were reported by survivors. Whatever happened, a
tremendous amount of carbon dioxide was suddenly
released, anywhere between 100 thousand and 1.6
million tons, according to various estimates.
Due to the inertia of the explosion, CO2
initially shot upwards at 60 miles per
hour. At 9 pm on that fateful day,
villagers heard a rumbling noise,
and many emerged from their homes to investigate.
They witnessed gas gushing upwards, forming a
cloud reaching up to 100 metres. Other survivors
described a white mist escaping from the lake.
But what goes up must come down, especially
when it’s carbon dioxide and one-and-a-half
times denser than air. Suddenly, the cloud
rushed back down to the lake’s surface,
before billowing outwards - like dropping
marbles on a pane of glass. Within seconds,
the gas cloud spewed from the confines
of the lake, rushing down the valley in
a wave that was fifty metres high, with
frightening speed. As it surged forward,
the carbon dioxide forced air out of its path,
and as it made its way through the villages,
people in its way lost consciousness. Colourless
and odourless, the silent and invisible killer
claimed human and animal lives alike, its
victims collapsing before suffocating.
The carbon dioxide was of a
strong enough concentration
that it killed not only the people of
Nyos but many of those in the Subum,
Kam and Cha villages up to 15 miles away.
In the closest village, only four escaped
quickly enough to survive. Most died in their
sleep, but even the so-called ‘lucky’ few were
permanently afflicted with breathing
problems, skin lesions and paralysis.
There were other volcanic gases present –
survivors recounted the smell of rotten eggs,
a sure sign of sulphur dioxide – but
it was CO2 that proved most pernicious.
A survivor recalled the scenes the following
morning: no birdsong or the buzz of insects,
only a deathly silence. People and animals lay
where they had fallen. Some survivors took more
than a day to awaken. Unsurprisingly, many who
did rouse believed it was the end of the world.
Scientists from different nations were
mobilised, but at first, they were all
baffled. There were numerous theories –
perhaps it was a vicious virus epidemic,
but the idea was swiftly dismissed as it
didn’t quite fit. The most popular view was
that a dormant volcano had bubbled and spit
poisonous gases, killing those around Nyos.
The true tale would only unfold in the ensuing
months and years, even though a similar tragedy
had struck the shores of nearby Lake Monoun two
years before, where 37 had died. But those deaths
were recorded as unexplained as the idea of a
limnic eruption wasn’t yet fully understood.
But now, the tragic toll of lost life at Lake
Nyos compelled authorities to take such events
more seriously, and scientists toiled to uncover
the cause. One of their conclusions was that the
very same tragedy could strike again, so they
devised a plan to prevent this. The team fashioned
a rudimentary device to let the gas vent from
the lake’s lowest depths through lengthy tubes.
Initially, the water needed to be pumped
up through the pipe, but once operational,
the outflow of gas from the ascending water caused
a self-sustaining effect that continually drew
more water upwards. Similar to siphoning petrol
out of a car, *cough* not that I would know.
In 2001, the first pipe was installed in Lake
Nyos, followed by two more a decade down the line.
By 2019, however, it was evident a single pipe
was enough to keep the carbon dioxide in check,
and so that’s what remains to this day. Hopefully,
keeping the residents forever safe
from giant explosive wet farts.